vamos a las noticias de la salud con
Mara Romero salamar Buen día para usted
Buenos días Ángela hay varios temas
sobre la mesa empezamos en Estados
Unidos ya son dos las farmacéuticas que
han comprometido su causa para reducir
los precios en la insulina en Estados
Unidos esto es bien importante es muy
importante como sabemos la insulina es
un medicamento perfectamente y
absolutamente vital para todas las
personas que tienen diabetes y esta ha
sido la farmacéutica
nordisco una de las principales
distribuidoras de este fármaco que se ha
comprometido en reducir sus precios en
un 75% a partir del 1 de enero del año
próximo escuchemos lo que decían en su
comunicado
nuevo nordis reconoce que algunos
pacientes tienen dificultades en pagar
por el cuidado de su salud incluyendo la
insulina por eso la compañía mantiene su
compromiso con reducir la carga de los
precios de bolsillo ayudando a
transformar el complejo sistema de
precios en búsqueda de una mejor
predictibilidad de precios la decisión
llega después de que uno de sus
principales competidores como veníamos
anunciando antes del 6 de marzo el Lily
también anunciara algo parecido redujo
los precios de dos de sus productos más
vendidos a un máximo de 35 dólares al
mes y siguiendo también las intenciones
del presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden que había intentado hacer de esto
una ley reducir los precios para todos
los pacientes de diabetes para todas las
farmacéuticas y solo lo había logrado
para los adultos mayores de 60 años el
acceso a la insulina en Estados Unidos
es de hecho un problema bastante grave
sobre todo donde hay más de 31 millones
de personas que no tienen ningún tipo de
cobertura médica es un sistema bien
intrincado de coberturas médicas Y hay
muchos que se quedan por fuera y además
particularmente los precios de la
insulina se habían duplicado más que
duplicado de hecho en los últimos 10
años y usted lo había predicho mar que
podía haber un cambio de tendencia
gracias a este cambio de las grandes
farmacéuticas y se cumplió se cumplió
pero el acceso a la insulina no
solamente es un problema en Estados
Unidos no no y además es que tanto él y
Lily como novo nordes que son estas dos
farmacéuticas de las que estamos
hablando también son de las principales
proveedoras en América Latina
particularmente y los precios en la
región tampoco es que sean bajos hemos
seleccionado algunos ejemplos algunos
países que hemos encontrado tanto de
humalog que es uno de los productos de
Lili como de nuevo rápido que es de la
farmacéutica nuevo nordis vemos que por
ejemplo en Brasil hay un precio de 89
dólares por un vial en Panamá de 80 el
nuevo bloque es más caro en Uruguay por
ejemplo que en Estados Unidos y en
Bolivia cuesta unos 29 Dólares un Vial
aquí yo tenemos que tener en cuenta
bueno principalmente que los precios los
salarios sobre todo son muchos más Bajos
en la región latinoamericana que no en
Estados Unidos por lo tanto esa
diferencia tenemos que tenerla en cuenta
que los pacientes que comprar a veces
Bueno varias veces más de un vial en un
solo mes para tener suficiente insulina
para pues combatir o mantener a raya en
control su diabetes y que por supuesto
la insulina como decíamos no es un
medicamento opcional para estos
pacientes que no tomarla o tener que
reaccionarla puede poner en riesgo su
salud gravemente no los precios en
Brasil y en Dominicana son terroríficos
dan mucho miedo sí pasamos a otro tema
pero ahora con buenas noticias para los
que toman café sí sé que en esta
redacción me regañan muchas veces porque
solo doy malas noticias que no podemos
comer no sé qué o que no dormimos
suficiente en este caso para las
personas que tomamos cantidades ingentes
de café que somos muchas en esta
redacción tenemos buenas noticias que
llegan desde el instituto carolinska de
Suecia que publicó un estudio en la
revista bmj empezaremos por el titular y
luego iremos a los matices que siempre
tenemos que dar el estudio básicamente
lo que concluye es que niveles elevados
de cafeína en el plasma contribuyen a
reducir el riesgo de diabetes tipo 2 que
es la diabetes adquirida por hábitos de
vida o también por la y que este efecto
protector de la cafeína se atribuye en
un 43% a que se reduce la grasa corporal
en el cuerpo que es uno de los factores
de riesgo que se tienen en cuenta para
el posible desarrollo de diabetes tipo 2
sin embargo como decía vamos un poco con
los matices en los estudios de nutrición
siempre hay muchos debates todo el mundo
quiere defender lo que le gusta además
suele ser muy difícil aislar el efecto
de consumir un producto con los efectos
a salud a largo plazo sin tener en
cuenta por ejemplo otros efectos como
hábitos de vida o factores ambientales
pero precisamente este estudio es lo que
quiere llegar a hacer así que en vez de
preguntar a la gente si toma cafeína o
no y ver pues qué tipo de enfermedades
desarrollan lo que hicieron fue
muestras de 10.000 personas y estudiar
dos genes particulares asociados con
Cómo procesamos la cafeína las personas
que tienen unos genes que determinan que
se procesa más lento tenían más cantidad
de cafeína en sangre durante más tiempo
y son estas personas con menos grasa
corporal y con menos diabetes así que
bueno intentando así aislar el efecto no
de solo de la cafeína sobre la salud Qué
significa este estudio Pues que cada vez
Es verdad que acumulamos más evidencia
en diferentes métodos y ámbitos de que
el café puede tener más cosas buenas que
malas que no significa pues que no nos
podemos poner a beber café pues
descontroladamente ni para adelgazar ni
para combatir la diabetes o prevenir de
la diabetes como que a nivel individual
no significa que tengamos que cambiar
particularmente ningún hábito Bueno
usted sabe que los defensores del ayuno
intermitente promueven el consumo de
café durante las horas de ayuno así que
bueno habría que contrastar como usted
dice no como siempre más investigaciones
la solución y sobre todo equilibrio más
bueno vamos a terminar con un tema sobre
los trabajadores de la salud y las
desigualdades sociales Esto está
causando un fenómeno de migración
Interesante pero también peligroso
también peligroso la OMS ayer lanzó esta
advertencia no de estos éxodos de
trabajadores desde países de ingresos
bajos a países de ingresos ricos con el
problema de dejar desatendida la
población del país de origen
escuchémoslo
los trabajadores de salud son la columna
vertebral de cada sistema de salud y aún
así 55 países con algunos de los
sistemas de salud más frágiles del mundo
no tienen suficientes y muchos están
perdiendo sus trabajadores de la salud
por la migración internacional la OMS
trabaja con estos países para apoyarlos
en fortalecer su fuerza de trabajo y
pedimos a todos los países que respeten
sus salvaguardas y recomendaciones
como dice la OMS 55 países vulnerables
por falta de trabajadores ocho se han
agregado nuevos a esta lista este año
por ejemplo Ruanda zambia o también la
mayoría están en el continente africano
o en el sudeste asiático y son países
que se consideran vulnerables porque
tienen menos de 49 doctores enfermeras o
comadronas por cada 10.000 habitantes
una pues muy falta Clara una Clara una
falta muy clara de habitantes de
personal médico para estos habitantes no
lo atribuyen entre otros por ejemplo al
impacto del covid 19 en los países del
Norte global Las bajas laborales que ha
provocado la presión
hospitalaria también las malas
condiciones que muchos países como de
Europa se están denunciando en este
momento Entonces los trabajadores dejan
de sus trabajos en el norte global y
estos países van a buscar esta mano de
obra en otros lugares donde les acepten
el trabajo la OMS recordó que no es que
eso esté prohibido la migración por
supuesto no está prohibida pero tenemos
que recordar la importancia de que el
bienestar de unos al final no vaya a
costa del bienestar de otros no es que
nos habla muchísimo de de la situación
de la pandemia no nos lo dijeron los
médicos de todas las maneras posibles
que con aplausos ellos no iban a
sobrevivir y lo mismo para todo el
personal médico y de las tareas de
cuidado y estamos viendo las
consecuencias Pues todavía años después
y las personas que tienen la posibilidad
de migrar si van a recibir un mejor
sueldo y una mejor calidad de vida Pues
por supuesto lo van a hacer usted bueno
Omar Muchísimas gracias a ustedes y nos
vemos mañana con más Gracias hasta
mañana